with a tidal wave of anger sweeping the
country
president macron stepped onto the
shattered streets
[Applause]
all around him desperate and furious
voices shouted out for reform
of a rotten political class which they
claim
is responsible for the blast
look at our family look at our houses
as he shook hands with victims of the
disaster and listened to their stories
he also told me lebanon needs much more
than just supplies of aids
i'm here to bring help to help to
coordinate we will launch a european and
international initiative
to bring money and help directly to
people
but at the other side we have to launch
a new political initiative
to change in depth what is today at
stake because
all this nervosity that you see
oh this this fear that's anxiety
and the anger you have is against
politicians
and against corruption in the country
everything is broken
a lot of things but you know in this
country you have marvelous people
lebanese people are so brave
so this is our chance
at times his security detail lost their
footing
on the pavements of broken glass
[Applause]
but the french leader did something here
that no lebanese politician would dare
to even think
he came and showed his face
what's happening here is quite
spectacular president macron's come on
to the streets
he's meeting people and hearing their
concerns
and for many they are seeing something
that they've perhaps never seen before
and that's his real leadership and
that's why they're coming to him
to demand for change but whilst his
walkabout was well received
this gesture will amount to nothing if
there is no concrete change
serena etchuffy told him not to trust
lebanon's government
who he'd meet later he says he's going
to meet with other political leaders
they're the ones that have been like
taking the country hostage since
1975. so what is your message to the
french president
i told him give the money to ngos give
the money to the people in need do not
give them to the president
the crowds here hope france lebanon's
one-time colonial ruler
and most supportive western ally will
soon be able to come up with a lifeline
along with the rest of the international
community
it is of course no easy task the country
is dealing with a major disaster
whilst already buckling under the weight
of economic and political crises
we need external help and support on all
different
aspects and levels to kick them out all
my business it's damaged
i don't mind look on my body it's
damaged
we don't care we want them to leave
lebanon
it will take billions to rebuild this
city
but the irony for many lebanese is that
the destruction of the port
is not even the real tragedy the ruins
here are just another terrible
symbol of a corrupt ruling elite who've
stolen all the people's wealth
and now their hope too alex rossi
sky news beirut